so for today's adventure they said they
wanted to do something fun so uh we got
a friend over at project N1 it's an
airsoft facility we were doing some
shooting they have no clue they probably
think we're gonna go eat some kind of uh
Filipino food or some [__] no we're
actually doing something good welcome
everyone to the first annual JK Hunger
Games
[Music]
that's not I don't like what the [__]
[__] look at this [__] dude
this is the owner of project N1 Airsoft
I have better teams what do you mean
minorities versus white people who do
you think is gonna win to be honest my
team because uh Bart's never played
Bart's been in the military but he's
never played Joel used to Airsoft weekly
so if it comes down to one-on-one I
actually put my money on Joe so I am
kind of scared I don't even know what
the [__] teams are I just know I'm
probably gonna lose
[Music]
like that
oh
[Music]
batteries
I don't know if you got me I got so good
if you know it
the game started I got you the [__]
ghost of camp out here dude
so like this is a lethal quarterback
it's not real guns but instead of coming
out here and then already getting hit
[Music]
thank you
[__] Jack Ryan that's also cornered
he like talks about a lot I just spent
my goodness
the next one is there's gonna be a dummy
in the middle of the field and then you
guys have to take it to the other team's
base so if you get hit while you're
carrying you gotta drop it yeah but if
the dummy gets it you're Gucci Gucci
Joe is like Seagal in there yeah
I just was sitting like this
what's up
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
damn
yeah
I was out of ammo too
I dropped my GoPro who brought it
I was out of ammo and everything you
can't stop [__] taking dogs Ryan has
to go and ladies and gentlemen oh my God
[Music]
foreign
I'm hitting people out here if you're
here Colleen I saw you I saw I saw
Clinton I just spray and I think I hit
people but I'm not sure
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
it feels good
I think Ryan there he is
oh my God
what they don't know is that I haven't
played in two years
[Music]
yeah it's not that he gave up it's
because he ran out of yeah that makes
sense I was like why didn't he shoot me
I was like I shot him like seven times
a knife and do the [__]
hey lazy yeah he lit my ass up
that was crazy
[Music]
all right let's be against him all right
let's do it
are you ready yeah okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
oh dude I'm dead that was good
holy smokes man I can't even breathe
that was a while
Ryan used to go every every Wednesday
for like a six months straight that was
so fun everyone versus Ryan real guns
real guys
best like cardio though did you just go
run it yeah you run it back and back
yeah thank you so much
project
here in El Monte have a lot of fun with
your friends
oh
hey
Jesus Christ there's no way that's legal
are we usually yeah
what is that it's like a dummies
dude I've been watching JK since like
they're used to do the songs back then
like what song was it every day I don't
know if you guys remember that well
there used to be the uncles back then
right and then so I was like in junior
high and up to now I'm still watching
you guys I watched JK news and I'm at
work I'm a floor later so I've been
selling my carpet and I'll be listening
to you guys in my podcast that makes my
day go by way quicker dude I've been
posting you guys since I was a kid dude
and honestly this made my day so much
dude thanks for having me guys man I
wish I was here for the event dude I
Wish I Was Here rapping this is cool
dude like this honestly probably made my
year oh dude
this right here is called beef chow fun
because when you child you have a lot of
fun
[Music]
[Applause]